. Musik Hallo, schön, dass ihr da seid zu einer neuen, fantastischen Folge von Das Podcast UFO. Das sind wir. Genauso heissen wir Das Podcast UFO DPU mit mir, Stefan Tietze und ihr Florian Tietze. Ich bin Florian Tietze und wir haben schon eine ganze Menge Folgen gemacht. Ich glaube, 212 Folgen schon. Jetzt kommt noch eine. Genau, jetzt kommt noch eine und wir wollen uns nochmal vorstellen, weil für für die, die jetzt das irgendwie zustalten, mein Name ist Stefan Tietze, ich bin 25 Jahre alt mittlerweile, nicht mehr 19 und ja, ich ja, du hast deine Ausbildung. Alle Vorstellungsrunden der Welt immer sind, die enden immer auf, ja, ja.
Sieb Luft holen, anfangen und dann, ja.
Also, da kommt aber nicht viel. Also im Gesicht ist sehr viel Energie eigentlich für, jetzt könnte eine Stunde lang Gesprächsstoff kommen, aber dann ist der Gesprächsstoff nach 30 Sekunden vorbei und das Ende mit einem, ähm, ja. Mir passiert es oft, dass ich zu viel Luft hole, auch metaphorisch gesprochen, ich nehme zu viel Anlauf, hole zu viel Luft. Und dann gegen die Wand. Gegen die Wand. So, ich weiß noch genau, wie wir damals in der Schule werfen gelernt haben, also so einen Ball werfen. Werfen gelernt? Oh, ihr habt ja ganz vorne angefangen. Ihr habt noch vorm Lesen und Schreiben mit Werfen angefangen. Aber worüber du dich jetzt lächerlich machst von deiner Sports-Jog-Goldpokal-in-der-rechten-hand-wedelnden-Position, sollte man ernst nehmen, weil ich weiß nicht, ob werfen so instinktiv jeder kann, gut werfen, das ist eine Kunst. Also ihr habt gut werfen gelernt, oder war das dann irgendwie LK, dem Werfen LK vorbehalten? Also ihr habt Werfen, Hüpfen oder Gehen, eins von drei könnt ihr euch aussehen. Und Zaubertränke, ist für mich ähnlich lächerlich, Werfen ist für mich ähnlich lächerlich wie Zaubertränke. Und da gab es dann auch immer den, der ganz viel Anlauf genommen hat beim Werfen, ganz schnell gerannt ist, dann an der Linie stehen geblieben ist und dann geworfen hat. Ja, eigentlich geworfen, eigentlich davor den Teil hätte er überspringen können. Der das mal gesehen hat, dass Leute Anlauf nehmen, aber nicht weiss, warum. Und deswegen rennt er einfach ganz schnell, bleibt stehen und wirft an. Das fand ich
immer am besten. So der, der weiss,
wie man es macht, aber
weil er nicht weiss, warum man es so macht, auch
falsch macht. Fand ich immer ganz toll.
Könntest du dich aber lustig machen mit dem Springen, LK.
Ja, ich hab ja wieder. Springen und Deutsch.
Ja, wir waren in Hüpfen, wir waren in Runterfallen,
Runterspringen,
einfach von so einem Bordstein runtergesprungen.
Hüpfen und Fallen, GK. Ich finde lustig, man ganzen Harry-Potter-Fächer kann man ja rüberziehen. Das ist ja alles ein Pendant zu Fächern, die es mir nicht gibt. Ja, aber wo ist Geschichte? Zaubertränke, na ja doch, die haben Geschichte der Zauberei. Aber machen die denn auch Hitler oder machen die halt dann nur ihr Zauberzeug? Nee, Zauberzeug. Hä? Die haben gar nichts über Drittes Reich und so. Nee, nee, es ist denen alles völlig egal. Haben die nichts mit zu tun. Die leugnen auch den Holocaust. Andere unangenehme Side Story. Aber jemals sowas wie Bio, da wo die diese Allraunen rausholen. Dann haben die Sport, Madame Hooch, das macht ja Fliegen und so. Dann haben die Zaubertränke, das ist ja eigentlich Chemie. Das macht ja alles Sinn. Dann haben die aber auch Verteidigung gegen die dunklen Künste. Was wäre das so in Deutschland, was wäre das Pendant zur Verteidigung gegen die dunklen Künste? Ja, stimmt schon, das waren dann immer diese merkwürdigen Stunden, wo man sich unter dem Tisch verstecken musste, falls ein Erdbeben ist oder ein Vulkanausbruch. Ja, eigentlich Amok-Alarm-Test. Das ist unsere Version von Verteidigung gegen die dunklen Künste. Ja, das wäre eine Amok-bung. Bisschen lamer. Aber cool, man hat es doch gefreut, weil man kommt mal ein bisschen runter. Ja, ist richtig. Oder rauf, je nachdem, wo man sich dann versteckt. Ja, ja. So, wir haben letzte Woche, ich muss es eben jetzt schon machen, weil die Internetverbindung ist gerade stabil. Wir haben letzte Woche nämlich diese grandiose Idee, wie ich nach wie vor finde, ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, man muss manchmal ein bisschen länger über gute Ideen schlafen, ich finde sie nach wie vor ganz, ganz grossartig, denn wir haben uns aufgefallen, dass der erste Artikel des Grundgesetzes, die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar, ein bisschen schwammig formuliert ist. Ein bisschen lasch. Ja, also ich würde sogar sagen, man kann da juristisch, können wir gegen vorgehen, weil die so dahingeschrieben wirkt. Uns ist aufgefallen, die deutsche Sprache verfügt über Wörter wie Halt zum Beispiel, mit denen du Sätzen besseren Ausdruck verleihen kannst. Die Würde des Menschen ist halt unantastbar, sagt Clara, dass es in Stein gemeistert ist, sagt Clara, die ist halt einfach unantastbar, was willst du machen? Deswegen wollen wir gerne eine Petition starten, um diesen Paragraphen zu ändern. So, ich sage von vornherein, es ist ein schwieriger Aufgabe, weil es der erste ist. Also das ist allein durch die Zahl eins schon ein bisschen, ist uns ein kleiner Stein in den Weg gelegt worden. Ich glaube, wir müssen die Petition aber auch nicht so mit wir wollen, sondern wir fordern und auch drohen, was wir tun, falls es nicht umgesetzt wird. Also direkt mit der Faust auf den Tisch zu sagen, jetzt pass mal auf, Freundchen, hier, Walter Steinbräuer, hier, jetzt, wer macht das eigentlich, wer kann den ersten Paragrafen ändern?
Ich glaube, der Bundesgerichtshof, Verfassungsschutz, Verfassungsrecht, der Verfassungsgerichtshof in Potsdam.
Ja gut, also, schreiben Sie hier die Petitionsüberschrift. Was wollen Sie erreichen? Wir sind auf change.org jetzt. Okay. Änderung des ersten Verbesserung, Verfeinerung, Verstärkung, Richtigstellung. Korrektur, lang überfällige Richtigstellung. Massiv wertender Titel. Umformulierung oder? Lange, lange überfällige Umformulierung. Überfällige Umformulierung des ersten Artikels des Grundgesetzes.
Kannst du Grundgesetz in Anführungszeichen nehmen, damit wir noch so ein paar Verschwörungstheoretiker mit reinkriegen? Ich glaube, die brauchen wir. Die unterschreiben gerne in die Position. Umformulierung, ich habe mich verschrieben, des ersten Artikels des Grundgesetzes, weiter. Perfekt. Also Change.org gefällt sich schon. Ausrufezeichen dahinter? Perfekt Ausrufezeichen, wer hat die Macht, die von ihm gewünschte Veränderung herbeizuführen? Moment, du hast ein Perfekt gekriegt von change.org? Ich glaube, alle kriegen Perfekt. Ist das so wie bei Dance Dance Revolution, wenn man alle Schritte richtig macht, dann kriegt man Perfekt am Ende. Bei Singster kriegst du so ein, nee, bei Singster kriegst du Rockstar. Popstar, Rockstar. Kommt auch die Singster-Version an. Achso, Hip-Hop-Star. Perfekt, wer hat die Macht, die von ihnen gewünschte Veränderung herbeizuführen? Toyotaute Frage. Zum Beispiel, Toyota oder Ihr Bürgermeister. Ich schreibe zurück. 70-30. Ich würde es auch mal an Toyota schicken, einfach nur um sicher zu gehen. Damit wir diesmal haben. Ja, ja, einfach damit wir diesmal auf dem Tisch liegen haben. Ja, ja. Auf dem Schreibtisch. Auf Wiervorlage. Ich sag mal, der Verfassung, wie heißt das denn? Der Bundesverfassungshof in Boxberg. Der Obergerichtshof, der höchste Gerichtshof der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Verfassungsänderung. So. Okay, kannst du das nochmal komplett vorlesen? Oh, ich habe schon auf Weiter geklickt.
Ich glaube schon.
Ja.
Sehr geehrte Demokratie...
Das ist immer dieser Thrill, auf die Zurück-Taste zu klicken.
Sehr geehrte Demokratieliebende und verantwortungsbewusste Damen und Herren.
Es gibt nichts Geringeres als den ersten Artikel des Grundgesetzes.
So, jetzt ist es raus.
Aber ab jetzt gibt es wohl kein Zurück mehr.
Aber genau der ist verbesserungswürdig. Erinnern Sie sich an den Wortlaut? Ganz genau. Die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar. Augenroll-Emoji. Das ist ganz schön schwammig formuliert. Das kann unsere schöne deutsche Sprache doch wohl besser. Die Forderungen deshalb klar und deutlich werden. Wir fordern das Wort Halt sowie ein Ausrufezeichen.
Über das Ausrufezeichen lassen wir mit uns reden. Das soll primär als Verhandlungsplan dienen und wird bei der erstbesten Möglichkeit über Bord geworfen. Der erste Artikel des Grundgesetzes soll deshalb lauten, die Würde des Menschen ist halt unantastbar. Wir sind bei Recht dafür. Das ist nicht so wichtig. Auf diese Weise kann der Satz unmöglich falsch verstanden werden, klingt umso prägnanter nach einem unbegsamen Fakt und klingt halt auch schöner. Vielen Dank für Ihr Engagement, das ist wachgerüttelte Demokratie. Das ist wachgerüttelte Demokratie. Jetzt unterschreiben Sie halt die Petition. Weiter. Perfekt. Foto hochladen? Nein. Nur gerne von uns, oder? Wie Foto hochladen. Profil vervollständigen. Von einem Grundgesetzbuch oder so? Oh, jetzt ist aber eben mein Klarnamen hier drin, das Podcast. Wie viel Unterschrift braucht man, um was zu bewirken für einen Putsch? Für einen Putsch glaube ich über zehn Millionen dann doch. Oh, na ja, gut. So. Alles klar, hier geht es hier los, Verfassungsgerichtshof, längst überfällige, Oh, dadurch, dass gut. Mega gut. Sehr, sehr gut. Auf Twitter gepostet? Auf Twitter haben wir es jetzt auch gepostet. Dann geht es jetzt hier los. Ich freue mich schon auf die ersten Reaktionen. Ja, wir können mal gucken, wie viel wir während der Aufnahme dieser Folge schon an Unterschriften sammeln können. Das war schon mal schön. Sehr gut. Das fühlt sich gut an, was geschafft wird. Ja, endlich mal was machen. Ich habe heute noch nichts geschafft, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Überhaupt nicht. Und deswegen bin ich froh, dass das jetzt zumindest irgendwie auf meiner Tagesliste abgehakt werden kann. Ich habe heute Nudeln angebraten und dachte mir, warum macht man das nicht häufiger, so Nudeln bewusst anbraten, so richtig knusprig braten, das ist so geil, warum gibt es das nicht in jedem Restaurant, so richtig so knusprig angebratene, wirklich so knackig knusprige, krümelige Nudeln, die so richtig crunchen im Mund, wo man so richtig... Da haben wir da vielleicht lautmalerische Sprache aufgedeckt.
Da ist man schon viel beim K.
Knusprig, knackig, ja.
Crunchy.
Das ist einfach, ja, das ist perfekt.
Grossartig.
Ich hatte gestern so einen Heisshunger auf Captain Crunch Peanut Butter.
Aber was macht man in Deutschland, wenn man Heisshunger auf Captain Crunch Peanut Butter hat?
Ernsthafte Frage.
Ich würde sagen, am nähesten dran ist noch ein Wonder Bar.
Da hast du Chunky Peanut Butter, Caramel,, da hast du ja auch, Captain Christ auch Karamell, halt eine Schokoladenhülle. Aber ich glaube, da bist du relativ nah dran.
Ist das ein Riegel?
Das ist ein Riegel, ja.
Kriegt man eine Tanke? Wo ist die denn gezeigt gerade mit dem Fingerchen?
Da ist ein Eckenkiosk halt da.
Eckenkiosk, okay.
Du kannst es heute holen.
Ja. Okay, gut. Ja, dann mache ich das mal. Kann ich das jetzt mal? Das ist genau der gleiche Kiosk, wo wir immer Marte-Run gemacht haben damals. Als wir bei guter Arbeit keine Lust mehr hatten zu arbeiten und gesagt haben, jetzt ohne Marte können wir jetzt nicht weiterarbeiten und dann haben wir uns eine Marte geholt. Das sind diese Übersprungshange, die es, glaube ich, in jedem Job gibt. Bei jedem Studenten, überall. Es gibt diese Handlung, die man macht. Aber jetzt mal dieses, jetzt mal in die frische Luft gehen, oder? Was man halt macht, meistens so nachmittags, 16 Uhr rum, eigentlich, weil die Pause am Tag liegt eigentlich falsch, wenn man ehrlich ist. Ich beginne morgens um neun, zehn Uhr zu arbeiten. So, und dann hast du zwei Stunden Arbeit, dann machst du immer um zwölf Uhr, halb eins, Mittagspause, ein Uhr, dann und dann hast du den Grossteil des Tages einfach noch vor dir. Und da muss zwischendurch, muss dann diese Marte-Run-Zeit, dieser, jetzt mal die frische Luft, diese kleine Pause dazwischen, die muss gemacht werden. Man arbeitet eigentlich fast nichts. Das ist wirklich so, man arbeitet eigentlich fast nichts. So, man hangelt sich zum Mittagessen und dann isst man durch, dann isst man voll und dann klickt man noch ein bisschen rum und dann auch nur noch eineinhalb Stunden bis Feierabend und dann, ja, packt man schon mal zusammen. Aber es wird angsteinflössend, weil ja alle so sind. Die Welt kommt ja nicht voran. Also ich glaube, wenn jetzt irgendwann Aliens kommen und sehen, dass wir halt eigentlich nur von Pause zu Pause arbeiten, aber als Weltwirtschaft nichts bespannen bekommen. Meinst du, das ist so zum Beispiel bei der Mafia auch so, dass die auch halt so einfach den Arbeitstag rumkriegen, dass sie sagen, oh, jetzt noch da den erpressen, ach, das machen wir morgen oder jetzt da nochmal rausfahren. Nee, das machen wir morgen in Ruhe. Das finde ich auch gut, den Satz. Genau, das machen wir morgen in Ruhe, ja. Der schönste Satz ist, das lohnt sich jetzt nicht mehr. Das lohnt sich nicht mehr. Herrlich, ich liebe diesen Satz. Und dann alle in diesem Schmierentheater des, ja, nee, stimmt nicht. Natürlich könne man jetzt sofort machen, wäre fertig eine halbe Stunde fertig. Aber nee, sobald einer mal diese Skepsis in den Raum bringt, so, aber lohnt sich das heute noch, haben alle die Ausrede zu sagen, das sind die wahren Helden. Die wahren Helden sind die. Die dann sich trauen zu sagen, wir können auch jetzt schon Feierabend machen, das andere lohnt sich heute nicht mehr.
Die Zweifel sähen, die den Kern legen, wo alle anderen sich dann so rumkondensieren, ihr Wasser so dran setzen, die einfach so sagen, ach, aber lohnt sich das heute noch so? Unherrlich, da hast du recht, stimmt, ja, ja. Das sind die wahren Helden. Und man merkt immer so, wenn diese eine Person geht, dann wird es nervös, dann wird es angespannt. Die Situation ist angespannt, weil man hat nicht diesen Ventil, der alle anderen, so diese ... Und machen wir uns jetzt vor, es ist oft die Person, die als erstes geht. Und auch die erste Person, die als erstes gefeuert wird, weil einer offensichtlich faul. Der diese Kettenreaktion anstösst, so diese Auslöser und dann spritzt alles rum. Ja, ja. Ne, das stimmt schon. Man schafft fast nichts. Ich habe auch jetzt, jetzt wird das Wetter da draußen
schön und man sieht im Homeoffice
bei Zoom und
Google Hangout die ersten Menschen
draußen sitzen.
Finde ich ja immer schwierig.
Ich behaupte, also ich bin der Meinung, die kennst du alle
als, ich gucke dann immer so zum Chef rüber
ins Fensterchen und gebe dem immer
so klare Gesten.
Er weiß nicht, wie man anguckt, ist bei Zoom schwierig. Aber klare Gesten, weil alle, die im Homeoffice sitzen, draußen sitzen, sind nicht nur unproduktiv, weil sie im Homeoffice sitzen, sondern auch weil sie draußen sitzen. Ich habe immer noch die These, dass niemand jemals etwas Sinnvolles draußen gemacht hat. Draußen wurde noch nie etwas erfunden, noch nie etwas Gutes geschrieben, kein grosser Literat, noch nie etwas Gutes komponiert, draußen wurde noch nie was, nagel ich mich drauf fest, gib mir ein Beispiel dagegen, es wurde noch nie was draußen wirkliches verbracht. Man hat noch nie in einem Film so eine harte Arbeit, Montage gemacht, so okay, wir müssen jetzt die Formel rauskriegen. In der Sonne. Und dann zack, zack, irgendwie Schreibmaschine. Und dann nie sitzt jemand draußen mit so einem Kinder-Schoko-Fresh draußen. Schneidersitz in so einem Grasbett. Nie. Immer in staubigen Kellern mit so einer kleinen Lampe oder so einer Kerze, die dann nochmal angemacht wird. Je weniger Licht, desto besser, desto kreativer. Genau, wo man dann so das Licht nochmal näher an das Blatt dran macht und so und Gandalf in den Katakomben von Gondor sucht die Sachen draus. Der sitzt auch nicht irgendwie draußen auf so einer Parkbank irgendwie und hat sich so einen Stapel Blätter mitgenommen. Hat einen Starbucks-Kaffee geholt, hat schön auf die Bank gesetzt in Washington Square Park und denkt nach. Nein, das passiert nicht. Selbst bei Harry Potter, wo es so viele freie Flächen gibt, auch da wirklich die intensiven Sachen immer mit so einer Laterne in der Hand, im Keller, ja, da wird gearbeitet. In den Verliesen, in der verbotenen Abteilung. Ich müsste auch viel häufiger ins Verlies. Ich weiß nicht, warum ich da so selten bin. Ich bin da so produktiv. Ich bin da am produktivsten im Verlies. Wirklich schön in den nassen, tropfenden Keller, wirklich, und da einfach sagen, jetzt nochmal schönen Nachmittag durcharbeiten, das ist herrlich, das braucht man einfach. Ja, also ohne Scheiß, draußen, ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben draußen was Sinnvolles geschrieben. Keine Zeile von mir, die mir draußen geschrieben hat, war irgendwas wert. Wir hatten jetzt gerade ein Gespräch mit jemandem, der vom Balkon runtergesprochen hat zu uns. Ich habe kein Wort verstanden, weil mich die Sonne so hart geblendet hat. Ich musste nach oben gucken, in die Sonne, ich hatte wirklich das Gefühl, ich habe zwei, drei Dioptrien verloren während dieses Gesprächs, weil ich so hart in die Sonne geguckt habe die ganze Zeit und nicht so den hier machen will, so dieses Sonnenlicht mit der Hand vom Gesicht fernhalten. Mit der Hand in die Augen des Gegners. Gesprächspartner sind immer Gegner. Sich eigentlich selbst die Augen zu halten, nee, da kommt nichts Produktives rum. Und ich weiss noch, genau in der Schule war es auch so, wenn es hieß, heute machen wir eine Stunde draußen, wussten alle, heute machen wir keine Stunde. Nee, keine Stunde. Perfekt. Oh, ist ein Käfer, nee, die Mareike schubst mich. Menschen sind auch für draußen nicht gemacht so richtig. Ich habe mich am Wochenende mal in den Park gesetzt, schön mit einem schönem Handtuch in den Park gesetzt und dann nach Minute zwei denkt man, warum sitze ich im Park? Ja. Die Idee ist nett, aber das zu machen ja nicht, weil du sitzt ja nicht gemütlich so. Stühle haben ja einen Sinn, thematisierte Räume haben ja einen Sinn. Deswegen ist eigentlich sowas wie Instagram perfekt, weil Instagram speichert diese Ideen. Du gehst in den Park für zwei Minuten, machst ein Bild und lädst es hoch. Und alle freuen sich, ah Park, toll, Sonne genießen und haben diese Idee im Kopf, ohne dann wirklich dieses, ich sitze auf dem Regenwurm, da ist ein Hund, da sind Bienen, da sind Wespen, irgendwie die Hornissen, die so eine Schlacht der fünf Völker austragen.
Die einzige Pokémon-Weiterentwicklung, wenn man mal ehrlich ist.
Bibor?
Nee, Biene, Wespe, Hornisse.
Eigentlich schon, ja. Aber wo ist die Bommel? Bommel? Hummel. Wo ist die Hummel?
Bommel?
Die Hummel ist so wie Habitak zu Taupsi. Weißt du? Ach so, das ist eine ganz andere Idee. Auch noch da. Hat gar nichts miteinander zu tun. Mein Bruder hat auch noch was gemahlen dürfen. Aber der sitzt im Ausschuss. Ja, die gibt es so in der blauen Edition dann. Ja. So, aber man spielt nur die rote. Aber die Bommeln sind nur in der blauen. Habe ich nicht verstanden. Habitag und Taubsee, dass man gesagt hat, haben wir jetzt alle Tiere durch, jetzt haben wir zwei Vögel. Ja. Habe ich nicht ganz verstanden. Von daher gibt es auch noch eine Daseinsberechtigung für die Hummel. Aber müssen, braucht sehr viele Vögel, ne? Vögel sind fantastisch. Ich kriege das nicht aus dem Kopf, worüber wir letztens gesprochen haben, nämlich dieses, weil du wieder irgendeinen Nonsens erzählt hast von der Musiktheorie und Dur und Moll und da hat keiner verstanden. Und warum man denn, weil auch so 440 Hertz ist A, warum ist das nicht 430 und dann hast du dann wieder gesagt wegen Bach und bla. Aber singen denn nicht Vögel auch in unseren Tonleitern? Das ist, äh, weiß ich nicht. Nee, glaub ich nicht. Warum? Die Kinder nicht den... Naja, aber vielleicht hat sich das gegenseitig bedingt, dass man... Ist ja auch egal, dass wir auf der... Nein, die hören nicht unsere Musik. Wir hören Vögel und das, was Vögel singen, klingt für uns schön, also haben wir auch unsere Musik danach ausgerichtet. Erstmal, so schön klingt das gar nicht.
Na ja, du, ich habe ein Video gesehen von einem Vogel, der hat ein Spinatblatt auf dem Kopf und war gut drauf und hat ein Lied gepfiffen und hat alle Vögel sind schon da gepfiffen.
Ich dachte mir, das ist es doch, ein Vogel, der alle Vögel sind schon da pfeift, dachte ich mir, geil, weil das ist sein Song, den mag er. Ich musste neulich für eine Freundin eine seltsame Aufgabe machen. Hintergrund war, das war wirklich die merkwürdigste Aufgabe, die ich seit langem bekommen habe. Sie musste ein Video schneiden für ihre Tante und ihre Tante hat ein Kakadu. Da war ich schon hellhörig. Was für ein Video muss ich schneiden, was ein Kakadu beinhaltet hat? Tante, Kakadu, okay. So, und diese Tante bringt dem Kakadu Otto Mathe bei.
Tante, Kakadu, Mathe.
Ja, Rechnen bei.
Otto lernt zu rechnen. Otto lernt zu rechnen. Warum kann man den nicht, also meine Frage, Kakadu sein lassen. Nein, warum muss er, weil Kakadus können erstaunlich gut rechnen. Und zwar lernt Otto jetzt bald die Zahlen bis 30 und dann kann er bis 30 addieren und substrahieren es ist ein scheiss kakadu und die idee also dann gab es ein video weil anscheinend geht er jetzt zum matheunterricht stell dir vor du bist in der mathe nachhilfe klasse und du bist und du checkst weniger als der scheiss Kackadu. ... der schläft gerade zum Vogel. Ja. Also, Otto hat die zwei plus und Jonas leider wieder die fünf. Was? Warum? Es tut mir leid, es tut mir wirklich leid. Aber guck mal, du hast hier Substration geschrieben, aber es heißt Subtraktion. Warum? Gehen Sie meine Rechtschreibfälle durch Mathe oder was? Ja, es tut mir leid, da müssen wir leider abziehen. Otto! Hehehehe! Otto, das gehört jetzt nicht dazu. Hüffelstein des Viertens! Ja, Otto, danke. Die Wurzel aus 39! Gut, haben... ja, jetzt interessiert es mich auch... Weiter, weiter... ...ist circa sechs. Na ja, nah genug dran. Toll. Aber das ist schon echt schlecht. Aber der geht jetzt in Matheunterricht, in so einer Volkshochschule, die sich auch nicht ernst genommen fühlt. Nee, so eine Kakadu-Schule, glaube ich. Naja, es gibt so hochbegabte Förderungen für Kakadus offensichtlich. Und man, also, und Otto ist schon aufgefallen, weil er schon als kleiner Kakadu sehr gerne gerechnet hat, während alle Kakadus durch den Käfig geflogen sind, hat der schon, er war ja der Aussenseiter, der gerne mal gerechnet hat und in welche Was-ist-was-Bücher gelesen hat. Und der hat jetzt angefangen zu rechnen und lernt die Zahlen eins bis zehn, kriegt dann also Zahlen vorgesetzt, also wie wir die kennen, arabische Schriftzeichen oder wie, oder was, arabisch, glaube ich. Und dann danach kriegt der verschiedene Bilder gezeigt und dann muss er auch das zeigen mit den fünf Autos oder den vier in dem Fall. Wie zeigt der? Schnabel. Schnabel. So ein Schnabel. Ja gut, okay. Der kann Zahlen checken. Der checkt jetzt die Zahlen und dann checkt er irgendwann das Zeichen für Plus, Minus, Mal und so weiter. Und dann kann er das, kann er bis 30, mal Richtung, kreuz und kreuz und kreuz. Warum 30? Ist das so das Limit oder was? Ich habe auch gefragt. Und das weiß ich nicht genau. Und dieses Video war ein Lernvideo. Und dann gab es aber leider eine Stelle, wo Otto für locker drei Minuten alles andere im Sinn hatte als Mathe. Und das tat mir ein bisschen leid, weil diese drei Minuten, die waren Otto für mich. Weil Otto hatte keine Lust auf Rechnen, sondern wollte Nuss knacken, hat auch viel in die Kamera geguckt und so weiter. Dann musste ich diese drei Minuten rausschneiden.
Der darf in dem Video nicht in die Kamera gucken? Nein, weil das war für die Trainerin, die nicht sehen sollte, dass Otto da unkonzentriert war. Also musste mein Schnitt auch so sein, dass man nicht genau sieht. Moment mal, du hast Dokumente gefälscht, um die Lehrerin der Kakadu-Schule zu betrügen. Das ist strafbar. Nein, ich glaube nicht. Du bist Komplize. Ich glaube nur, dass ich Otto mehr unterstützt habe, als vielleicht andere Leute ihre Kakadus unterstützen. Und vielleicht ist Otto gar nicht so begabt, aber weil er so eine Familie hat, die so hinter ihm steht, wird er jetzt ein bisschen mehr gefeatured. Weiß ich nicht. Ich finde es auch nicht gut, was ich da gemacht habe, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Ich bereue mich auch gerade sehr doll, aber jetzt, ja, wird er gefördert. Aber die nächste Mal der Stunde ist es wieder im Mai, Mitte Mai. Wow. Wir bleiben dran auf jeden Fall, was bei Otto so passiert. Ja, vielleicht können wir ihn auch mal einen Podcast einladen, weil das interessiert mich wirklich. Ja, und dann fängt er ja irgendwie rumzurechnen und so. Ist ein bisschen nervig. Ich finde ihn nervig. Ja, Otto ist jedenfalls, doch, können wir ja mal machen. Finde ich sehr spannend. Spannendes Geschöpft. Sehr schöner Kakadu auch, sehr schön. Aber ich komme immerhin noch nicht darüber hinweg, dass Leute Vögel einsperren. Das ist das Grausamste, was es gibt. Ja, vor allem, dass man die Tiere einsperrt, die offensichtlich bei der Definition am meisten Freiheiten haben. Dann nimmt man als Mensch, will man das nehmen, weil man neidisch auf Flügel ist. Ja, ich würde mal gern so fliegen wie ein Vogel. Ich wäre gern so frei wie ein Vogel, vogelfrei. Okay, gut, schlechtes Beispiel. Bestes Beispiel. Ich wäre gern mal so frei und dann denkst du, ja, aber dann die Leute, die es haben, die Vögel, die sperrt man ein. Ja, weil die haben es ja. Die schneit man die Flügel ab, stutzt man weg und bringt den Rechnen bei. Und bringt den Rechnen bei. Das Leben ist nicht nur ein wenig, dass sie einfach ein genauso schlechtes Leben haben wie ihr müsst. Das Leben ist nicht so nur rumfliegen und schnattern, das Leben ist auch Rechnen, Steuern zahlen, eingesperrt sein. Guck mal hier, du hast fünf Nüsse und davon gehen zwei Anstatt. Die krieg ich und die kriegst du nicht. Das ist wirklich die nächste Form von Sadismus. Nicht, dass man Tiere tötet und isst, sondern dass man ihr auch wirklich das Leben aktiv schwer macht.
Du wirst sterben, also nicht mehr die Zahlen beibringen, sondern das Konzept vom Tod.
Wir haben jetzt auch Lesen beigebracht.
Du wirst eines Tages sterben.
Siehst du erstmal die Leiden des jungen Wärters, dann gucken wir mal weiter.
Also erstmal Kafka, alle Werke und dann gucken wir mal weiter.
Gucken wir mal, wie es dir geht. Gucken wir mal in deine wachen Kaka-Augen, wie es dir dann auch geht. Ich glaube, der Mensch kann es nicht ertragen, dass es Lebewesen gibt, die freier sind als er. Man muss alles auf sein Niveau runterziehen. Ja, genau. Also Flügel weg, Käfig. Ja. Woher sitzen wir nicht auch metaphorisch in unserem Käfig? Ja. Aber ist man nicht manchmal in einem Käfig auch freier als in der Freiheit? Oh ja. Ich habe jetzt wieder Shawshank Redemption geschaut, den objektiv allerbesten Film aller, aller, aller, aller Zeiten. Laut IMDb steht er auch so. Ja. Der hat keine Sterne, sondern ist der aller, allerbeste Film in aller aller Zeiten und den habe ich mal wieder geschaut und da dachte ich mir auch wie gern ich im gefängnis wäre weil ich glaube da wäre ich der freiste mensch weil du keine opportunitätskosten hast du kannst ja nur geilen scheiss machen ich glaube es kommt darauf an warum im gefängnis war es wenn du eine coole story hast aber wenn du irgendwie so ganz dumm ausgerutscht bist irgendwie irgendwie, du bist von... Mit dem Messer in den Polizeibappen reingefallen worden. Und dann wolltest du weglaufen und dann bist du nochmal ausgerutscht. Dann kommst du nicht ins Gefängnis. Und dann wolltest du sagen, nein, ich war es nicht und dann wolltest du ausweichen, bist dann aber so ein bisschen umgeknickt und dann warst du ein bisschen locker im Schuh drin und bist nochmal hingefallen und so und dann wurdest du gefasst. Und das ist, glaube ich, nervig. Dann denkst du dir immer, wäre ich doch nicht ausgerutscht. Wäre ich jetzt nicht hier? Aber wenn du eine coole Story hast, irgendwie keine Ahnung. Cooler Mord. Halt irgendwie, ja schon Mord, aber halt irgendwie dann halt Baby Hitler getötet oder so. Niemand versteht dich und nur du weißt, dass du die Welt gerettet hast. Solche Geschichten, wo du halt denkst so, okay, ich bin hier drin, aber die Welt weiss gar nicht, was ich für sie getan habe und so, so dass man sich selber so diese romantische Geschichte erzählen kann, dann ist geil, glaube ich, dann hat man auch so manchmal so, wenn du so irgendwie in der Werkstatt arbeiten oder so Bohrmaschine, das ist dann auch cool, aber wenn du brauchst, dann eine gute Geschichte, glaube ich. Nimmst du Angst vor Bohrmaschinen? Ja? Ja. Ich musste neulich bohren. Um ein lächerlichlich großes Bild in meiner neuen Wohnung aufzuhängen, musste ich in die Wände bohren, Betonwände, habe ich nicht geschafft. Ganz, ganz, ganz, die sind so hart wie Beton halt. Weiß ich auch nicht, da muss man diese Baumaschinen anschliessen, da habe ich schon auch noch Respekt vor. Ja. Weil die schon auch sehr viel Lärm macht. Ich habe Angst vor Dingen, die so viel Lärm machen und so endgültig ja auch sind. Vor allem, wenn du bohrst in so eine Wand rein, ist da immer ein Loch drin. Was mich immer irritiert ist, ich bin mir hundert Prozent sicher, also du bohrst ja ein Loch und dann kommt da so Staub raus. Ich bin mir hundert Prozent nicht sicher, dass da weniger Staub rauskommt, als Loch am Ende ist. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Irgendwas geht da verloren. Ja, das denke ich mir auch. Aber wo ist das? Das kann nicht sein. Du presst es in das Loch rein. Du presst auch eine Menge ins Loch rein. Aber das dreht sich doch so. Ich verstehe es einfach nicht. Ist jetzt nicht das allerwichtigste. Gibt wichtigere Dinge im Leben, wie zum Beispiel die Petition. Aber das muss ich nicht verstehen. Aber ich weiss, das sind manchmal so Sachen der physikalischen Welt, die ich nicht checke. Ich weiss zum Beispiel noch, dass ich als Kind ganz lange Scheren nicht gecheckt habe. So, wir machen eine neue Petition. Scheren? Ja. Ich habe als Kind, ich weiss noch genau, wie ich mir den Kopf zerbrochen habe, ich dachte immer, wenn man Blatt in zwei Teile schneidet, dann gibt es am Ende weniger Blatt als davor. Also die beiden Blätter danach sind weniger als das Blatt davor. Warum? Irgendwie hatte ich das in meinem Kopf und ich habe immer meinen Vater gefragt, wo ist aber das, wo ist der Rest hin? Es gibt keinen Rest, es sind dann zwei Teile. Ja, aber wo ist der Rest? Da ging es nicht weiter und ich hatte es ... Schatz, heute ist er wieder gekommen und hat wieder gefragt, wo der Rest ist. Diese Papiersache, die geht nicht aus seinem Kopf raus. Ich weiß nicht, was wollen wir denn machen? Wir müssen ... Ding Dong! Ja? Hallo? Guten Tag, ich hole die Sachen ab.
Welche Sachen holen Sie ab?
Die Sachen, die ich jede Woche abhole.
Was für Sachen holen Sie ab?
Moment mal, sind Sie derjenige, der den Rest abholt?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Sie sind's, er läuft weg, hinterher, er hat die Reste! Er ist ausgerutscht! Er rappelt sich auf, er ist wieder ausgerutscht! Hey, sie! Hey, er läuft weg, seine Schuhe sind locker! Er ist aus dem Schuh gestürzt, er ist abgeknickt! Tollpatscheste Mensch der Welt! Aber so wird es mir passieren, ich könnte nie wegrennen. Ich hätte auch so immer diese, ah, ein Rüpel hat meine Handtasche gestohlen, ihm hinterher. Ich nehme mir, pass auf, also entweder. Freunde, wir können hier aufhören mit der lustigen Szene. Ja, ich nehme mir so, pass auf, entweder ich mache mir jetzt so ein Deppen und laufe hin und renne gegen irgendeinen Roller oder so, oder wir lassen es und ich kaufe dir eine neue Handtasche. Das ist mir lieber, als jetzt hier irgendwie... Du bist auch einer der wenigen Menschen, die ich mir nicht über rennend vorstellen kann, gar nicht rennend vorstellen kann. Du existierst auch nicht rennend. Nee. Du existierst jetzt eher rückwärts laufend als rennend, wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin. Ja, es gibt keinen Grund zu rennen. Es gibt... Nicht mehr. Ich glaube, irgendwann kann der Mensch auch nicht mehr rennen, weil das ist nicht mehr nötig. Man muss sich aktiv dazu zwingen, zu rennen und joggen, ansonsten könnte man das nicht mehr. Bestimmt. Werbung. Hey Leute, mal ganz kurz ein kleiner, ernsterer Hinweis. Es gibt wahrscheinlich einige von euch, die mit der aktuellen Situation rund um Corona ein bisschen berufliche Schwierigkeiten haben, wo es nicht ganz so einfach läuft. Und für die haben wir einen kleinen Hinweis. Denn es ist wichtig, auch in diesen Zeiten speziell online aktiv zu sein, online zu sagen, man existiert und generell die Marke in digitalen Zeiten aufzubauen. Und zusammen mit OMR hat Audi jetzt unter dem Hashtag Audi Together die Videoreihe Go Digital gestartet, in welcher euch Philipp Westermeyer erklärt, wie ihr am besten euer Business online bringt. Wie ihr am besten euer Business online bringt. Also wenn ihr Freelancer seid oder kreativ arbeitet oder in der Gastronomie arbeitet und einfach von der aktuellen Situation betroffen seid, dann habt ihr da die Möglichkeit, euer Unternehmen oder euren Job oder was auch immer ihr tut, eben online darzustellen.
Genau, Audi Together sind 15 Videos, das ist ein kostenloser Crashkurs, den ihr euch angucken könnt. Falls euch das interessiert oder jemanden kennt, den das interessieren könnte, dann schaut doch mal auf YouTube bei dem YouTube-Kanal von OMR vorbei oder sucht nach Hashtag Audi Together. Werbung Schneidet man wirklich dann Atome in der Mitte durch oder schneidet man genau zwischen zwei Atomen, aber die sind ja nicht genau in einer Reihe. Betreibst du nicht im Prinzip Kernspaltung? Weil wenn du an einem Punkt zwischen die Atome schneidest mit der Schere, dann schneidest du eine gerade Linie. Du kannst ja nicht auf jedem Punkt dieser geraden Linie exakt zwischen, es muss ja irgendwo ein Atom mit zwei Teile. Du spaltest ein paar Atome. Und dann hat das eine Blattseite nur noch so ein Halbatom und das andere ein Halbatom und dann verflüchtigen die sich, weil die nicht existieren können oder was weiss ich. Irgendwo ist da irgendwas auf der Spur. Irgendwo ist da was. Ich bin in den Gedanken nicht so doof. Irgendwo ist da was. Aber jetzt ist es eine gute Frage, weil ich habe jetzt ein paar Löcher gebohrt und ich bin mir sicher, da ist nicht so viel rausgekommen, wie ich eingebohrt. Ich probiere das mal aus. Ich nehme ein Blattpapier, schneide es hundertmal durch und dann gucken, ob es wirklich hundertmal so viel wiegt danach. Wiegt es? Oder wie viel wiegt es danach? Ich glaube, wenn du einen mikroskopisch nahen Schnitt rangehst, siehst du auch, dass er nicht glatt ist. Da bist du oben, du bist rumgetorkelt um die Atome. Nein. Doch. Wie geht das? Naja, du hast eine ungefähr gerade Linie gemacht, aber mikroskopisch klein ist natürlich wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig uneben und unglatt. Das ist, glaube ich, der Denkfehler, den den gerade hast. Aber was hält die da damit zusammen? Das hat uns mal Philipp Hauptmann erklärt. Wir haben ihm die Frage gestellt, wenn man zwei Blätter Papier fest genug aneinander drückt, werden die dann nicht zu einem Blatt Papier. Wie ein Kaugummi, beim Kaugummi klappt es ja. Ja, und im Grunde hat er gesagt, wenn man die fest genug aneinander drückt, dann geht das auch. Aber man bräuchte halt so wie der Sonne oder so. Aber das war so ein, ich lege jetzt aufs Satz. Ja. Das war so ein Ja. Ja, genau. Wenn man das bei Ihnen vielleicht, bei euch. Das Handy ist schon fünf Zentimeter vom Ohr weg. Ja, okay, alles klar. Wenn ihr beiden das macht, dann klappt es. Ja, genau. Bei euch klappt es bestimmt. Fünf Tonnen Mega-Joule, ciao. Irgendwie bin ich da, ich weiß nicht. Ja,
forsch da mal nach. Das ist für mich das neue, wieder ein Kühlschrank-Experiment, was ja auch ein
großer Erfolg war, besonders die Auflösung, kam mir auch sehr gut an, wo man halt, da hätte ich
gerne das nächste alltägliche Problem, dem du auf der Spur bist. Mein Kühlschrank ist mittlerweile
völlig außer Kontrolle, weil irgendwie, es gibt ja so diese klare Trennung, Kühlfach, Kühlschrank, easy. Hä? Kühlfach, da ist eiskalt. Eisfach, von mir aus. Eisfach, wenn du deine eigenen Wörter jetzt ausdenkst, von mir aus. Eisfach, eiskalt, Kühlfach, kühl. So, haben wir. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, bei mir im Kühlschrank haben die sich verzettelt irgendwie. Die sind irgendwie durcheinandergekommen, so sorry, ich dachte, ihr seid das eisfach. Achso, nee, nee, nee, wir kühlen nur. Hä, aber wir kühlen auch. Aber wir machen Eis. Wir kühlen hier die ganze Zeit nur. Hä, aber da liegen doch Eiswürfelschalen bei euch. Naja, lass dich doch mal hier abhängen. Wir haben eine gute Zeit für die Eiswürfelschalen, was auch immer das ist. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Guck mal, wir haben hier Getränke und Joghurt und so. Guck mal, bei dir, das ist Spinat, tiefkühlspinat. Wir haben eine Zitrone hier liegen. Die hat schon auch nichts im Kühlschrank verloren, die hat noch weniger im Gefrierfach verloren. Da musst du gar nicht mit anfangen. Einiges war es ja nichts im Kühlschrank. Ja, das sage ich dir auch. Du, letztens Flasche Ketchup, Nutella. Boah, Alter. Ey, und dann macht der auf und tut hier Senf rein. Und ich denke mir, Alter, bist du völlig gestört. Und ich sage euch noch, Zitrusfrüchte. Okay, macht man mal als Anfänger den Fehler.
Aber hier immer wieder Sachen reinzuwählen. Ja, letztens Knoblauch.
Oh mein Gott.
Hey, ich weiß noch, vor einem Monat fängt der an hier irgendwie Bananen rein.
Ey, ich bin völlig gestört.
Aber nicht so zu trotz, ihr seid schon das Eisfahrt.
Ja?
Ja klar, guck mal, was liegt da direkt neben dir?
Tiefkühl Spinat.
Ja.
Tiefkühl.
Ja, tiefkühl.
Ja, ist nicht Eisspinat oder so oder Eisbergsalat. Naja, ach komm. Naja, aber so gekühlt. Wie kalt können denn werden? Naja, halt null bis fünf. Null bis fünf? Ja. Ihr habt Wein bei euch da drin liegen. Wein? Wein, Weisswein liegt da in einer Flasche Weisswein. Ja, Weisswein gehört ja nicht in einst eisfach. Nee. Einer von euch muss jetzt eisfach sein, weil es gibt ja keinen Sinn, dass wir zwei Fächer sehen, aber keiner ist Eis. Jungs, Eis machen! Alles klar, na gut. Wir können ja nächsten Monat wechseln, okay? Ja, weil es ist auch, es wird auch frisch hier, muss ich sagen. Ja. Okay, ich lege auf. Wir sehen uns. Ja, warum willst du denn schon auf? Ich muss jetzt weitermachen. Was? Womit? Die Kühlung regulieren. Alles klar. Gut. Du musst leider auflegen, weil du angerufen hast. Ich kann nicht auflegen. Ach so, hä? Was für ein System? Ich weiß nicht, aber ich würde jetzt wie gesagt aufhören und dann. Gut, ich. Ciao. Du musst auflegen. Ich stehe jetzt auf. Ja, alles klar. Ciao. Leider nett. Und deswegen ist bei mir jetzt im Kühlschrank Riesentohu-wabohu und bei mir fangen Sachen an zu gefrieren, die eigentlich im Kühlfach
liegen und Sachen, die im Eisfach liegen,
fangen an zu aufzutauen. Letztens habe ich mir
einen schönen Joghurt zurechtgelegt.
Abends auch mal mit einem schönen Joghurt.
Mach den Joghurt auf,
durchgefroren. Löffel
stösst auf Granit.
Gut, war es ein Fruchtzwerg?
Hoch, nein.
Fruchtzwerg kann man auch ins Eisfach machen. Wenn zum Eis, einfach so. Ja, aber stopp, stopp, stopp. Der Munde ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehrach machen, während so einem Eis, einfach so. Ja, aber stopp, stopp, stopp, da muss man aber davor einen Löffel oder irgendwie so einen Eisriegel reinstecken, weil ansonsten dann leckt man sich da an der scharfen Kante da die Zunge wundt oder was. Ist das nicht genial? Ja, es ist genial. Ein Fruchtzwerg ist auch ein Eis, du kannst es benutzen, wie du willst, ist wie so eine B-Seite. Ja, aber du kannst ja auch einen Löffel in die Zitrone stecken und die Zitrone gefrieren und dann halt die Schale abknibbeln und dann die Zitrone lecken. Kleiner Tipp. Wow. Service-Tipp. Das ist ein mega Tipp. Das ist ein wirklich aggressiv formuliertes Rezeptbuch. Ja, mein Gott, 200 ml Milch und halt drei Eier und dann rühst du es halt zusammen, mein Gott. Guten Appetit. Wenn man so Rezepte sich über YouTube anguckt dann immer und die Leute sich nicht bewusst sind, dass man es immer wieder anhört auch und es dann mal so weird, ein weirdes Kontext hat. Ich habe so ein tolles Koch. Dein Weinen, das hast du mal erzählt. Ja, der weinende Italiener, der das Lieblingsgericht von seinem verstorbenen Freund gekocht hat und dann weinen musste. Aber ich hatte auch so ein Barbecue-Video mal angeguckt und da machen die so Kräuterbrot und dann machen die halt so Kräuterbrot und dann sagt der, wir haben jetzt noch was von dem Butter übrig, jetzt machen wir noch eins, weil wir haben ja Zeit. Und dann diese acht Minuten, die es gedauert, das Brot zu machen, zeigen die genau noch mal. Was, echt? Und ich dachte, ihr könnt auch schneiden, ihr müsst doch nicht alles zeigen, weil das Video war geschnitten mit Anfang, Intro und allem und dann so, ja, wir machen es einfach noch mal, weil wir haben ja Zeit. Ja, Kollege, so funktioniert es nicht. Ich gucke immer so Sportvideos, diese macht man ja jetzt so, weil man kann ja keinen Sport machen.
So Hip-Hop oder was?
Nee, dann, so funktioniert es nicht. Ich gucke immer so Sportvideos, diese macht man ja jetzt, weil man kann ja keinen Sport machen. So Hip-Hop oder was? Nee, dann einfach so Übungen. So ein Olympionike hat so seinen Trainingsplan reingestellt, filmt sich dann dabei, wie er dann so Bauchübungen macht zum Beispiel. Und dann mache ich diese Bauchübungen mit ihm und der erzählt halt immer so Funfacts dabei. Und es macht dich halt rasend, weil du an Tag drei diese Funfacts mitsprechen kannst, weil du immer das gleiche Video anguckst und so. Die sind nicht auf diese Reproduzierbarkeit gemacht. Das muss nicht mit dem Klaren sein, auch Rezepte, die guckst du da dabei. Und wenn du dann schon wieder über den Freund weint, dann irgendwann ist er auch vorbei, kannst du nicht mehr mitfühlen. Es gibt nichts Schlimmeres als schlechte Erklärvideos.
Und worüber ich auch oft nachdenke, ist, dass es in den Anfangstagen von YouTube gab es ja Videoantworten.
Echt?
Man konnte ein Video auf ein Video.
Das ist die dümmste Idee der Welt.
Das ist die beste Idee der Welt.
Du konntest auf ein Video mit einem anderen Video antworten.
Also du schaust ein Video und sagst, ja meiner meinung zu dem video genial genial fantastisch doch grossartig und das würde ich gerne auch machen jedes tutorial das es gibt nehmen neu schneiden und als antwort auf dieses tutorial posten weil in der regel sind tutorial siebeneinhalb minuten lang und du brauchst davon vierzehn Sekunden. Ja, das gilt für alles auf der ganzen Welt. Ja, irgendwie keiner, wie mache ich diesen Effekt, dann hallo, ja mein Name ist, diesen Effekt, alles egal, du brauchst nur, klick hier hin, dahin, dahin, dahin, aus. Kein Intro, kein Outro, keine fliegenden Buchstaben durch die Gegend, sondern einfach nur, ja du musst dahin klicken. Keine Entsch Entschuldigung fürs letzte Video. Das stimmt, das fällt schon oft auf. Das ist wie bei Telefonaten, wo du halt die ersten 40 Minuten katten kannst, die letzten 50. Weg! Und inzwischen brauchst du zwei Sekunden, in denen du klärst, wann man sich trifft. Ja, oft brauchst du einfach nur, ja, du musst da hinklicken, aus. Ja. So, zeig mir einfach nur bei Photoshop, was du machen willst, wenn zwei Ebenen übereinander sind und du willst nur eine davon sehen, klick hier drauf, done. Zwei Sekunden. Das Video ist wirklich zwei Sekunden lang. Und das würde ich gerne machen, die Neuschneiden, so, das war ja auch meine Idee, das Internet in klein, so Pocket Internet nochmal, so das ganze Internet nochmal in klein, so auch wie so Artikel, da hast du dann so einen Artikel und da nur Nonsens drin steht du willst ja aus so Artikeln oft nur einen Satz so wer ist jetzt Kanzler und dann so fangen wir an Menschen schlangen vor der Wahlkabine dort drängten sich junge da ist mir scheiss egal in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat die Wahl des Kanzlers. Oh, ich hasse das. Ja, ja, ja. Man kann alles kürzen. Wir werden durch, ich glaube, wir werden jetzt schon durch mit vielen Dingen. Wir hätten schon auch mal alles gelernt, einmal verstanden. Ja. Diese Fragen mit, geht beim Born was verloren, reint sich auch schön, by the way, hätten wir gar nicht, wenn es alles in den Pocket gäbe, dann wüssten wir das ja schon.
Dann wüssten wir warum.
Ja.
Oder nicht, warum nicht.
Nein. Nein, oder ja, je nachdem.
Geht beim Bohren, was verloren ist schön.
Das ist ein schöner Buchtitel.
So heißt die Folge.
Geht beim Bohren, was verloren.
Heimwerken für Anfänger und du mit so Schulterzucken auf dem Cover so, ich weiß es wirklich nicht.
Ich weiß, ich sollte nicht dieses Buch schreiben. Ich finde, es klingt aber auch wie der Anfang eines Sprichworts, was dann weitergehen müsste. Ja. Geht beim Bohren, was verloren. Ja, genau. Holt man sich heiße Ohren. Ja, ja, als müsste da noch die Leere kommen. Ja, genau. Wir haben schon ein paar Reaktionen auf unsere Petition. Auch wirklich? Positiv, negativ, neutral oder? Amsel schreibt, bin ehrlich gesagt gespannt, was daraus wird. Okay. Dann, endlich engagiert die jungen Leute euch mal für was. Das ist doch bestimmt von Bill Gates organisiert. Ja, oh, viele Betrugungstheorien jetzt mit Bill Gates. Moment, aber sind das jetzt Kommentare auf der Change-Seite oder auf Twitter? Nee, auf Twitter. So. Ja, ein bisschen unsinnig, dass die vorgesehen hat, bestimmt schon. Ich gehe mal kurz auf die Petitionsseite. Wie viele Leute haben unterschrieben? Oh, wir haben schon 32 unterschrieben. 32? Ja, von 100. Wie, dann 100, dann ist du fertig, oder was? Nee, nächstes Ziel ist 100, weil es eine komische Formulierung ist, weil dann ist nächstes Ziel 1000. Es gibt immer ein nächstes Ziel. Wir müssen ein Bild machen. Ah, es gibt schon einen Kommentar. Nächster Halt, Ausrufezeichen in der Sachsen-Anhalt. Finde ich so schlecht. Wegen Halt, ja. Und die WC-Ente, Halt ein WC-Schwan ist. Ja. Ne, davon haben wir uns schon verabschiedet. Sehr gut. Oh, und der Smiley hat es nicht überlebt. Der Smiley ist eine Raute mit Fragezeichen.
Das sind die schlimmsten Emojis,
die man nicht weiss, was es ist.
Ich freue mich, dich zu sehen.
Was? Ironisch,
ernst, blau, dieser scheiß blaue
Herz. Freut es sich jetzt, mich zu sehen?
Ja, was heißt das blaue Herz? Weiss ich nicht,
aber ich weiss nur, ich hatte
mal irgendwann ein schwarzes Herz gesehen. Ich dachte mir, das ist entweder so emo-mäßig, irgendwie so unerwiderte Liebe oder halt irgendwie so schmerzhaft oder halt irgendwie sowas. Todesherz. Und dann habe ich mal gefragt so, hey, was heisst es? Und dann hat mir jemand geantwortet, ja, das schwarze Herz, das postet man total viel in der Geocacher-Szene. Und ich dachte mir so, bitte was? Also Geocacher sind die Leute, die irgendwie so eine Box vergraben und dann die Koordinaten davon irgendwo posten und dann kommt jemand anders und holt die Box raus. Und in dieser Szene scheint man anscheinend dieses schwarze Herz zu benutzen. Und es war so viele Fragen, ähnliche Fragen. Und ich habe aufgegeben an dem Punkt. Wirklich? Ich habe aufgegeben, ja. Ich würde gerne wissen, warum. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Manche Emotis sind echt Quatsch. Ja, vor allem, ich habe da jemanden auf Tinder kennengelernt und wir haben ein bisschen gechattet und sie hat dann geschrieben, hey, ich freue mich, dich zu treffen, schwarzes Herz, was könnte das heißen?
Ja, sie ist in der Geocacher-Szene.
Ja, direkt blockieren.
Bist du, aha, und dann ist man direkt angesprochen als auch Geocacher.
Vielleicht ist das so ein bisschen so ein geheimer Gruss.
Aber ist das so wichtig den Leuten, dass sie Geocacher?
Bist du auch?
Ich gebe dir mal meine Koordinaten. Gruselig auf eine Art. Es ist gruselig. Kann man Koordinaten einfach bei Google Maps eingeben und dann was, ja. Klar. Ja? Ja, ja. Das ist eine selbstbewusste Antwort. Das geht, ich habe mir jetzt Google Earth runtergeladen tatsächlich. Runtergeladen? Ja, aber viele wissen ja nicht, dass es einen Unterschied gibt zwischen Google Maps und Google Earth. Okay, den Unterschied kenne ich auch nicht ganz genau, aber das eine lädt man runter und das andere geht halt so im Browser. Das eine ist unnötig, weil es das andere gibt. Nie und dann, ja, auf jeden Fall hat man das dann halt runtergeladen und dann kannst du da so die Kugel rumstupsen und dann kannst du damit auch das alles. Kannst du damit auch, also, kannst du damit auch Routen berechnen? Man kann Routen berechnen, ja. Bei Google Earth? Ja, ja. Das war neu. Und, nein, keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Ich hab nur, weil ich hab nur eine Karte von einer Fantasy-Welt gebraucht und da gibt es manchmal so Mods für Google Earth, wo dann so Mittelerde drauf auf den Globus projiziert wird, sodass man dann eine Karte von Mittelerde hat, aber halt wie ein Globus. Also man kann dann halt reinzoomen, rauszoomen und dann Distanzen auch sich angucken und so und dafür habe ich das gebraucht. Und es ist aber so ein bisschen heil, weil da schimmern dann die alten Städte noch immer so durch und da hast du dann Rohan. Neben Mordor ist einfach Göttingen. Ja genau, und das heißt soöttingen. Und manchmal, ist das jetzt Teil von Mittelerde, oder sind das noch so Überbleibsel? So wie ich ja früher mit meinem Cousin habe ich eine Radioshow gemacht als Kind und das so über Bibi-Blocksberg-Kassetten drüber aufgenommen. Und da war immer noch so... Manchmal die Todesschreie von Bibi auf dem Scheiterhaufen. Noch so alte Sachen. Da habe ich letztens auch mal drüber nachgedacht. Unsere Bibi-Idee. Wir wollten ja damals bei guter Arbeit, wollten wir ein Hörspiel machen. Mit dem Original. Bibi und Tina, Schauspieler. Genau, wir wollten Bibi und die Zeitmaschine. Und Bibi findet eine Zeitmaschine in irgendeinem alten, verlassenen Reiterhof, den sie renovieren soll, findet eine Zeitmaschine und benutzt die mit Tina. Um ins Mittelalter zu reisen, weil es eine coole Zeit war. Ja, sie sind irgendwie große Game-of-Thrones-Fan, irgendwie Ritter und da sie Hexen sind, werden sie einfach gejagt, gefoltert und verbrannt. Ja, das war die Idee. Und ungefähr die Hälfte von diesem Hörspiel sollten nur Schmerzensschreie von Bibi und Tina sein. Fanden die Brecherinnen von Bibi und Tina nicht so lustig wie wir? Auch der Verlag fand sich so lustig. Ja, generell alle waren keine großen Fans. Ich glaube, die haben erst geantwortet, als sie meinten, wir wollen Bibi Blocksberg-Hörschel machen. Und die so, ja, coole Idee, so was habt ihr euch vorgestellt. Und wir so, ja, die sollen brennen. Und die so, nee, das macht auf gar keinen Fall. Also nee, überhaupt nicht, da verstehen wir gar keinen Spaß. Und damit hat sich das erledigt. Wir ja auch nicht. Nee, ist ein ernstes Thema. Ja, wir wollen uns ja auch nicht über den Tod lustig machen. Nee. Und über Hexen. Nee. Oder Inquisition. Ja, technisch gesehen war es nicht Mittelalter, sondern Renaissance. Da werden bestimmt wieder 50 Leute schreiben, deswegen nehme ich das jetzt schon mal vorweg. Es wären eh nur zwei
Lach-Emojis gewesen von Patrick,
der irgendwie geschrieben hätte und
dann sehr viele Leute gesagt hätten, das ist aber gar nicht Mittelalter
gewesen. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ist dann okay.
Naja, geht, geht. Genau wie
ganz viele Leute geschrieben haben, dass es nicht
Werner Röntgen heißt,
sondern anders. Ja, mein Gott,
Leute, da seid ihr immer richtig schlau
schlau gewesen. Viele Leute haben es geschrieben. Ja. Mir Gott, Leute. Habe mich vertan. Da ist halt immer richtig schlau gewesen.
Viele Leute haben es geschrieben.
Ja.
Mir hat einer gesprochen.
Ganz schlaue Leute.
Wo kriegst du denn diese ganzen ...
Ja, alles an die Zentrale halt, an die fucking nervigste E-Mail-Fresse der ganzen Welt.
Ja, aber Leute, die Zentrale ist auch nicht irgendwie so eine Funfact-Rotz-Ablage.
Nee, das ist die Rezeption.
Ja, das ist für wichtige Sachen auch. Ja, das ist so hochoffizielle Dinge für seriöse Anfragen. Und du gehst ja auch nicht zum Daimler-Vorstand irgendwie und gehst da in das Haupthaus, da eine Rezeption, um da irgendwie zu sagen, ne, irgendwie... Sterne sehen eigentlich gar nicht so aus. Ja, und Petrol ist eigentlich eine andere Farbe für ihr Filmenlogo. Nee, nee, nee.
Nee, genau. Also deswegen nochmal, an zentrale at podcast-uwe.fail, das ist ja
unsere E-Mail-Adresse, bitte nur ernste
Anhängen mit wichtigen Themen,
mit denen wir was anfangen können.
Diese kleinen Funfacts, so dass wir hier eine kleine
Korrektur machen, dass es Wilhelm Röntgen war,
das brauchen wir da nicht. Das schickt ihr einfach direkt
an jemand anderen. Schickt ihr direkt an
florentin.will at gmail.org.
Ach ja.
.org.
Ich verstehe nicht genau Org.
Gibt es eigentlich mordor.org?
Gibt es das eigentlich?
Ist das nicht ein Gag?
Kann man das nicht so machen?
Wie heißt die E-Mail-Adresse von Sauron? Dot org oder so? Das ist ein echter Witz! Sauron at Mordor.org. Den witz hat es hundertprozentig immer gemacht. Kannst du den bitte raushauen bei Twitter? Wie gut, wenn dann ja nichts mehr kommt
und dann, was ist die E-Mail-Adresse von
Sauron?
Sauron at Mordor.org
Aber
Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum das lustig ist.
Das versteht auch niemand, aber schreibt man es mit G oder mit C?
Das mit K.
Org. Wie schreibst du Org?
Ach so, ja, ja, im Deutschen kannst du mit Org schreiben.
Mit K, aber Englisch oder C?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Bei dem Tweet würde ich es fast mit K schreiben.
Das ist ein gesprochener Witz.
Hau dir jetzt raus.
Ja klar, es ist ein Jahrhundert-Gag.
Wie heißt, aber auch mit diesem lächerlichen Witzanfang, wie heißt die E-Mail-Adresse von Sauron.
Und dann kommt lange nichts und Leute schreiben so, was, ja, wie denn? Ja, genau, einfach eine Stunde lang erstmal nichts. Und dann vergisst es den Gag zu schreiben. Gut, jetzt hat das abgebrochene Vorgang, seht ihr nicht, Handy da weggelegt, jetzt starrt er nur noch in den Raum. Ja, ich hau's kurz raus dann. Nee, ich hau's gerne raus. Oder über das Podcast-Ufo ist es dann wieder so ironisch, oder? Flo und den hat sich mit flinken Fingern an seine Tastatur gesetzt, die Finger huschen über die Tastatur. Ich habe damals in der Schule einen Schreibmaschinen-Kurs gemacht. Okay, also Schreibmaschinen-Schreiben. Oder hat er Vorspringen oder Hüpfen oder? ne einen Schreibmaschinen-Kurs gemacht. Okay.
Also Schreibmaschinen-Schreiben. Also Vorspringen oder Hüpfen oder?
Nee, Schreibmaschinen, also halt zehn Finger schreiben.
Ja.
Aber ich kann es bis heute nicht.
Nee, ich bin auch sehr schnell im Schreiben und alle fragen immer, kannst du mit, du schreibst ja auch mit zehn Fingern, das ist immer so ein Urban Myth.
Der Chefmann schreibt ja mit zehn Fingern, nein, tut er nicht, er schreibt mit vier.
Wirklich, das müssen wir heute mal korrigieren. Ja, ist ein Urban Myth. Der Chef und schreibt ja mit zehn Fingern. Nein, tut er nicht, er schreibt mit vier. Wirklich, das müssen wir heute mal korrigieren. Ja, es ist ein Urban Myth. Urban Legend. Aber ich bin so gespannt. Ja, da ist er. Wieder die E-Mail-Resse von Sauron. Sauron at Mordor.org. Eine gute alte Twitter-Folge mal wieder. Ja, eine gute alte Twitter-Folge. Früher ging es bei uns um 80 Prozent um Twitter, muss man auch mal sagen. Ja, stimmt schon. Ich habe Twitter irgendwie verloren so ein bisschen, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Nein, Twitter hat dich verloren. Ja, Twitter hat mich verloren und ich habe Twitter ein bisschen verloren, aber so muss es sein. Ja, ich finde es super, dass du es veröffentlicht hast. Für mich gibt es ein dickes Like. Oh, wie wichtig das damals war, wer liked welchen Tweet und wie viele Likes in welcher Zeit. Damals waren es noch Sterne. Da war es noch Sterne und wenn man nach fünf Minuten nicht hundert Sterne hatte, löscht man wieder und so. Löscht man sich und springt von der Brücke. Das waren schon so ein bisschen unsere Maßstäbe damals. War ein anderes Leben. Heutzutage geht es eher darum, worum geht es heutzutage? Bilder bei Instagram wahrscheinlich eher. Ja, oder halt einfach ein gutes Leben leben. Oder ein gutes Buch. Ein schönes Buch. Ein schönes Buch mit schönen Bädern. Hast du mal Buchtipps? Ich kenne mal Buchtipps mal wieder von dir. Hau mal so die Top 50 Bücher raus von dir. Also, Platz 50, Reklam, Kafka, die Maus, ne, Yes, die Maus, der Käfer, der Käfer, Kafka der Käfer, Platz Nummer 49, Schiller die Glocke, er ist einfach richtig gut, Platz Nummer 48, Kafka das Schloss, toller Klassiker, 47 ist Goethe die Faust, ganz, ganz wichtig, und 46 bis 1, eigentlich diese lila Reklamheftchen, die verschiedene Sachen erklären. Die sind eigentlich immer spannend. Die sind schon gut, ne? Und da auf Platz 1 Relativitätstheorie. Lese ich einmal im Monat, weil es ungefähr einen Monat dauert, bis ich alles wieder vergessen habe, und dann kann man es wieder neu entdecken. Kann es wieder neu entdecken, entdeckt viele neue Dinge, die man nicht verstanden hat. Und wie dieses Video,
was ich mich einmal im Monat angucke,
über die Videoreihe,
Video-Essays über den
Butterfly-Effekt, Chaos-Theorie,
wo ich, während ich es gucke,
immer mich wie erklärwester Mensch der Welt fühle,
weil ich es verstehe, plötzlich,
und dann krisselt der Kopf und man denkt,
jetzt ist man so in einer neuen Welt,
weil dieses Video ist wirklich fantastisch, das einem erklären, und dann vergisst man es wieder. It's so blatant, heisst der Channel. It's so blatant. Toll. Ja, hört mal rein. Also, kommt ganz gut an der Tweet, sag ich mal. Ja, ist das so? What? Der erste Kommentar bin ich jetzt im Podcast-Ufo, ja. Na gut, mich schon durchschaut. Oh, du hast die Polizei retweetet? Dein vorletztes Retweet war die Polizei, sei kein Blender, check einfach selbst, ob dein Licht richtig eingestellt ist. Ach so, ja klar. Das sind Herzensangelegenheiten, ne? Ja, ja, dieses Blenden, das ist mir sehr, sehr wichtig. Davor hast du eine Serie empfohlen, How to Sell Rock Online First. Oh, die ist so gut, ey. Die habe ich so gern geschaut. Du bist wirklich sehr lustig bei Twitter. Gut, Ich für meinen Teil
wünsche euch eine ganz, ganz tolle Woche.
Kommt gut rein.
In die nächste Woche.
Wünscht euch einen guten Start in die nächste Woche.
Lasst die Woche gut ausklingen
und wenn ihr in der Mitte der Woche seid,
hängt euch rein.
Hängt euch rein und
kann ich noch kurz was anhängen?
Klar, gerne.
Was ich vergessen habe.
Weil
mir ist was eingefallen,
denn bei Patreon
Patreon
oder wie man auch immer das nennt,
kann man uns ja Nachrichten schicken,
wenn man eine gewisse Summe spendet.
Ja! Und das haben wir schon
ein bisschen länger vergessen. Deswegen lese ich mir
jetzt zwei Nachrichten vor. Zum einen hat uns vielen Dank Joscha Schubald geschrieben, Ja! Spiele Magic Online, bin ich wegen Florentins Videos wieder draufgekommen und etwas pappen geblieben, dafür eher nicht so, danke.
Und zunehmen wir gleich wieder eine Dosis DPU rein, in diesem Sinne, mach weiter so, don't shut up and take my money, hdgdl, Joscha, vielen Dank dafür. Vielen Dank Joscha, also, falls ihr auch eure Nachricht völlig lustlos am Ende der Folge vorgelesen haben möchtet, dann spendet gerne oder macht was anderes. Und John hat noch eine Nachricht geschrieben, hi Flontin, hi Stefan, da ich jetzt Spender
bin, würde ich jetzt Spender bin,
würde ich mich darüber freuen, wenn ihr in einer der nächsten Folgen
gern in einem genervten Ton nach der Anfangsmusik,
ohne Bezug zu meiner Nachricht, sagen könntest.
Es wäre ja schön, wenn Herr Vierbein auch endlich mal eine verdammte Anfangsmusik schicken würde.
Naja, liebe Grüße, liebe Grüße und danke für auch wieder meinen Podcast,
auf den ich mich Woche für Woche freue, John.
Vielen Dank dafür, das sind eure Nachrichten gewesen, die ihr für viel Geld habt, ihr euch diesen Platz erkauft.
Ich hoffe, das war es wert, haut rein, habt eine schöne Woche und ich würde sagen, das einzige, was übrig bleibt, ist abzuheben.
Das ist das einzige, was übrig bleibt.
Stefan, aktivier den Turbo Boost, los geht's.
Ja, ich leg den Hebel um.
It's a Westboro Production.